with any kind of speaking just like any
kind of writing just cut that you've
you're doing a science experiment what
they're our component parts so you have
to look at those pieces say the kids
okay so you've seen a speech before
you've seen somebody talk and you get it
now let's look at the pieces and let's
break it down you know you look at an
introduction what information are they
giving you in that little itty bitty
piece that leads to the the main
structure of the body but then it gives
you all this knowledge and then how do
they wrap it up how they tie those ends
together at the very end and there have
been people who have said that the
amount of work that a varsity debater so
junior senior level debater puts in for
a topic like that is as much or more
work than someone who is doing their PhD
dissertation and these are high school
kids you know 14 15 16 17 18 year-olds
core doing that kind of research and we
wonder why they're becoming leaders
because they get it and they're able to
switch off of an affirmative or negative
have been ball size every round they
switch sides what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Alan sockin
we're on site in the beautiful Sioux
Falls South Dakota we are now going to
be talking about Speech and Debate we
have Jennifer Bergen gabor joining us on
the show hums burger hello thank you so
much for coming on the show absolutely
thanks for having me I love it I was so
excited miss Bergen was my debate
teacher during high school and she's
made a profound influence on me and so
many other students now for those who
don't know her background she's been
teaching for 27 years in South Dakota
currently at Roosevelt High School in
Sioux Falls teaching speech debate oral
interprets she was also the oral
interpreter bit coach being a find her
links in the bio below
miss bergen let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world
who it scares me some days it really
does you know I just coming from South
Dakota and farm background and all of
that and and what all the the trade
implications that are going on right now
and you know we've got more and more
farmers that are filing bankruptcy and
there's not gonna make it it's like okay
what's how we gonna fix this because
once that happens it's gonna affect all
of us here in town too we don't we live
and die by all of us working together
we're a small state where you know in
this region and we really have to hold
together and it really worries me and
then you start talking about climate
change and you talk about glaciers that
are disappearing and all of those things
and there's just so much going on and
it's like wow and I have a little one
and what's gonna be left for her when
she gets to be my age so it concerns me
I think the political climate right now
is is very frightening it's just it's so
black and white and and we've lost that
that area of grey where people would get
together and say okay we have to do some
give-and-take for the best of everyone
and and that's really frightening so I
you know I don't know where that's gonna
take us a lot of the spiritual leaders
and spiritual teachings for the last
thousands of years have talked about
this connection to the diviner to source
or to nature and the more that we have a
whole connection to that the less
fragmented we are the less we have
issues that develop in our world and so
the more that we then develop our own
connection to divine and then help the
social fabric become more and more which
is
beautiful and ethical and just maximize
the people bringing the gifts of all
different sorts of gifts forward into
our world it seems like that would solve
so many of the issues that we have but
it is it does seem like does it does it
seem like it's that like that
fragmentation away from nature away from
source away from those things I don't
know I mean I think about you know the
whole big phrase out there now and you
see it on shirts and you can see it
everywhere and it's like if you can't be
any you can only be one thing be kind
and I think some people miss the boat on
that it's like that's not just being
kind to yourself that's being kind to
everyone that's understanding that's
respecting that's that that's saying you
know what we're different but that's
okay in you know I talked about the
political climate and I think that so
much now it's things that I saw when I
was a child as far as you know the the
ethnic name-calling and and the racial
slurs and and all of that and oh we
can't you know this in the funny part is
you know I remember my parents and my
grandparents talking about how oh and
the Germans came out you know those
German neighbors there were problems and
they'd you know it doesn't matter what
immigration group it is it doesn't
matter what you know if they're
different than the rest of us we're
afraid of them and what we should be
doing is embracing them because they
bring new and and together the things
that we can come up with and make this
world a better place you know it's like
no they're not invading us they're
enhancing us it used to be that we would
say come check in and and bring what you
have and and do the best you can with it
and we'll work together we'll become
neighbors you know and yeah it just it
scares me you mentioned the gray area
the nuance the importance of
multivariate conversations to figure out
like what is our common sense making
mechanism that we can best move forward
with and that very much so feels like
it's under attack by radicalization by
cognitive ease tribalism
echo chambers algorithms needs all this
type of stuff and also just the
addiction to instantaneous gratification
and pleasures rather than this like okay
it's gonna take a while but we have to
like sit down and write out all the
different variables and the complexity
of it okay okay now on the journey who
are you growing up I probably never
asked my teachers about who they were
growing up and why they became
interested in what they got interested
and now this is like the thing that I
care most about is like yeah and so now
finally I was so yeah I'm the middle of
five who had a sister six years older
than I am and so when she moved out at
18 and never came back I was an only son
only daughter with three brothers and
there was lots of change with that
besides that we at that same time moved
from living in small town Minnesota back
to South Dakota and living and started
living on the farm so I was out working
with my brother's you know side by side
hand in hand doing farm work and my
sister wasn't nowhere to be found was
moved on to college and everything else
both of my parents are educators my mom
was a teacher my dad was a principal we
laughed about the fact that we weren't
sure how the last you were gonna
graduate because dad wasn't gonna sign
their diploma yeah you know I said every
kind it kind of came the running fun
joke so we moved several times growing
up because of my parents jobs and those
kinds of things and so kindergarten
first second grade I was in three
different schools moved again then when
I was out of sixth grade in seventh
grade moved again going into my
sophomore year high school and I look at
those and I go yeah it was kind of tough
and yeah it was whatever the other funny
thing is all of the all of the research
everything even back then said middle
school years or your toughest years you
know that's sixth seventh eighth ninth
grade that's
the toughest try and keep your kids are
stable and in it whatever every one of
the five of us moved at some point
during those time periods and so we
laugh about that it's like you guys were
educators you guys knew and you moved us
anyway you know so but the benefits of
having to adapt to new situations are so
amazing yeah you know I even have
conversations now with my students and I
say how many of you were born and raised
and you've never been anywhere but right
here oh what percentage would you say
say that they have only been in one call
I would say it's at least half yeah
that's pretty interesting you know
because we've become so globally diverse
and in Sioux Falls that's become less it
used to be probably three quarters
mm-hmm you know well we moved across
town yeah that's not what I'm talking
about
oh I switch from this elementary but
this winter I went to middle school out
no that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about major cultural shifts I
like how you talk about this adaptation
that you experienced being like a
beautiful lesson for you learning
experience you're looking at it like
like you're like kind of like learning
from an in gaining experience from it
and not like that it like something
happened to you that I harmed you or
hurt you yeah I mean I was a little
miffed after sixth grade because we
stayed in one place for five years I
didn't want to move right so that was a
little tougher but again I grew from
that there were there were some things
that weren't so much fun but there were
other things that I grow I still say
going back to the town where our farm is
that some people still look at me like I
have three heads because oh my gosh we
can make a small town South Dakota and
we'd lived an hour from Minneapolis st.
Paul and we'd been there we saw the big
city and we knew there was a you know
and and they were just like well we went
to Sioux Falls and that's like two hours
away and some of them hadn't even but
not far away from home so in this is
literally 70 so you know we're in as
mobile we weren't doing as much of that
kind of stuff that we do now now nobody
even questions that you just go so you
know that became that became that
cultural that was really the hardest
cultural shift for me
is because people just kind of looked at
us like oh you think you've seen the
world and you know better and we and so
they would not necessarily treat us very
nicely but I still learned from it and
I'm not saying that everybody was that
way because they weren't I still have
some some good friends from those years
but being able to walk into a situation
step back to take a picture of what's
going on size up the people in it and
then be able to step in and become part
of it mm-hmm huge huge huge you know I
probably the best example I was ad I was
involved in 4h and you know so a lot of
like 4-h is a youth organization and so
you know it's live it's farm kids and
it's City kids and it's everybody but
it's its leadership and it's it's it's
working with you know all the different
kinds of things anything from arts and
crafts to gardening to sewing to you
know showing livestock and all of that
so my brothers and I were involved in
that when we were when we were back in
and on the farm and I loved it I mean
just the people I met and all that okay
so well most of those people are in
cowboy boots and you know Western jeans
and and that kind of stuff and I was at
the State Fair several years and
probably one of the first couple years I
was teaching so I mean I had been out of
4h for about ten years and I'm sitting
there with all of my 4-h II cowboy a
Western II Evo where your checkers kind
of people and we're just talking and and
all of that and in walks this guy I knew
from living in Aberdeen whom I'd done
karaoke with well he's in a heavy-metal
rock band so he's long hair and he's the
love there any and they're all just
looking at him like a nice walking right
toward me and these guys that I am are
friends of my friends like so I don't
even know them personally are starting
to get up often out their seats and it's
like I better in treating real quick
here but when I when I dealt with that
situation I said you guys he's cool you
know we know each other he gives me a
hug and we you know we start talking and
there's
just by a pure it's just by parents they
were like why are you here yeah and I
thought about it out for that right and
I thought about after that my way man I
really have kind of a chameleon mm-hmm
and I can kind of weave in every I mean
I put on the fancy clothes whatever and
I can fit into the company
the Richie's and I can fit into the
everydays and I can you know I can just
do that and that comes from having moved
around and that comes from having gotten
to know people
my mom always joked that we brought home
strays and mostly me if you're calling
my friend strays okay but I but I would
I would those are the people that I
would say hey you know what you've got
somebody here that'll that'll stand up
for you don't be a dick friend group
yeah and I find that even with my
students I watch out for those kids that
really look like they're struggling yeah
that don't have people going hey how's
it going today or you know they don't
have that friend group they don't have
they just kinda look like lost souls so
that's that's been something I've been
doing since I was little kid yeah my
people those are the greatest people
around
I agree yet the ones that the most
non-conforming people are definitely
some yeah yeah years ago hey look at
some of my students I go you are such a
freaking amia what is it oh no no in
that's a compliment
yeah you know you not somebody who just
fits the norm and follows the rules and
you actually try to expand the world
yeah and you question it and you and you
try to go outside of that oh okay he's a
kite freak it's okay yeah I love weird
freak crazy I love those words yeah yeah
they actually a major catalyst for
innovation and creativity being
expressed fully otherwise you can get
quelled by conformity yeah absolutely
cuz if everybody's did then we're just
machines and we're just Adam Autzen
so this is you and this was you in high
school this is me growing up okay and
then how then in your later years were
you like I'm interested in teaching so I
went and got my bachelor's degree I pick
Concordia Moorhead Minnesota did speech
communications theater arts new I loved
it but I also got a degree in home
economics which now everybody calls
facts family consumer sciences and I
wanted to work as a youth director in 4h
that's where I wanted to go I want to go
back to what had given me all of that I
knew that no matter what I did that's
the age group I want to work with I love
working with teenagers and even some of
the younger kids and I had done a couple
summers and in the in the Extension
Office doing some of that stuff so I
knew that it was something I loved well
there was kind of a glut in the market
at the time so I get home I'm farming
with my dad because I've got one brother
off with up with people traveling the
world I've got one that's a senior in
high school once off in college so dad
they are tractor driving he made the
mistake one day of saying hey why don't
you go in and get lunch ready I said how
about whoever tractor runs out of gas
first cousin makes lunch my dad made
lunch all the time he it's like whoa
where did this little sexist thing come
from and I just kind of laughed inside
my head knowing I had the bigger gas
tank he caught the message real fast but
my dad were room and I were really tight
so that was kind of funny so I spent you
know time doing that and went oh wow my
student loans are coming too you know
I'm living with mom and dad I'm on the
farm yes I'm working but everything I'm
doing is you know I'm right there so I
looked at what else do I want to do with
my with my degrees and I ended up going
and getting my master's in counseling
mmm and focus on mental health and focus
truly on alcohol and drug addictions had
a college roommate who was an alcoholic
and not somebody who drank all through
high school alcoholic she have anything
to drink alcohol wise and does she went
to college but her biological system was
such that the second she did
that was it game over and she and I
lived together our sophomore year and I
went up you know when she went to
treatment and all that so that just
became a real passion for me it's like
okay so this is another way I can help
people so I got that degree I went and
did some work at Macross and Boys Ranch
and also then worked at a Human Services
Agency and did a lot of alcohol and drug
stuff created a group where I worked
with teenagers who you know made bad
choices and got arrested for whatever so
whether it was a underage or they and
getting a DUI or you know whatever was
then I created a group and and I would
have group meetings with those kids like
once once a week and I did most of the
individual stuff I also got to teach the
UI class where most of those people said
I only had one drink your blood alcohol
was point to yeah yeah double the legal
limit and how big was the glass right
and the funny part was when a friend of
a friend ended up in my DUI class and I
was just like okay yeah yeah okay
there's lots of um youth for drug
alcohol counseling as well as adults and
so okay so so you kind of had this this
early desire to help people with their
with their healing and with their growth
process and the reef Lauer
you know bring you stray some yeah okay
okay and so then that was going on first
a couple years
yeah okay and then it was like okay I
get it I hear the voices in my head and
supposed to be teaching and I went back
got my teaching degree mmm and that's
where I've been I took I took a year I
taught for five years and they decided
that I should be the debate coach and
teach facts classes and I was like yeah
yeah I did it for one because they
needed me and I was like no no no no
we're not doing this again I had two
separate classrooms two different parts
of an old building
piecemealed together so I was like
[ __ ] between the two and they said I
can't do it to me and I can't do it to a
sub mm-hmm
and so every side and then I took a year
off just to reevaluate if I was gonna
stay and teach hmm and then I did get
back in into just one of those instead
of just both yeah and since then it's
always been language arts speech you
made dinner not fax as well no more yeah
that would be really hard yeah well
those are two very challenging and
there's I mean there's things that
overlap you start talking about child
development and understanding those
kinds of things that you know and that
was the joke it was single survival and
child development that I taught and you
know I'd walk in the office and they go
but you you're surviving as a single
right now and like it's not the same
thing as teaching it so yeah I never
mind teaching it but I just knew it was
gonna be too much too much stress on me
and too much stress on everything else
and I wasn't gonna give a hundred
percent everything and this was then
like 90
that would have been 97 7 yep Paul 97
spring of 97 okay and then that was that
do well and I hope that was up in Africa
Burdine first yes Aberdeen was first and
what year was the first student where
you were the first students like I
started teaching in the fall of 93 92 92
and because I was lamenting the fact
that I was in school when Roosevelt
opened mmm it was like oh my gosh
there's a debate opening there's the
knee and it's like oh my gosh everybody
all these positions are gonna be filled
and I'm gonna be a year behind him and
there are gonna be jobs so I was a
little nervous because I was then
student teaching while everybody else
had these jobs that I thought I was
gonna have a chance at and there was a
big shift in the debate community which
you know once that happens that usually
settles in for 5-10 years okay okay so
so what would the age group in
to start for you so I was teaching
debate to sophomores because at that
point aberdeen central had still the
junior high so the freshmen were over in
another building they could come and be
part of the team they could be in
activities but they were in a separate
building so we only had 10 11 12 graders
in that building so I had sophomores for
debates I had I was teaching junior
English which was you know the research
paper comp and American Lit somebody
else was teaching speech who didn't have
a degree in speech and it was like wow
you know and that but I love teaching
they the lid and stuff to I mean I just
again you can start talking about the
the whole connections you Society and
all of that it's always been high
schoolers oh okay yeah okay
and then where was she was about four
years then 15 5 and everybody and then
where's do what dual isn't clear like
isn't clearly which is between if you if
you take a triangle and make it between
Watertown Brookings in Camby Minnesota
okay it's right there boom okay okay and
then there was another like four I was
there for six six years and that's also
where I went to high school oh that's
really enticing because back then it was
so-called Clear Lake High School they
had done some consolidating okay it's
the same thing Speech and Debate in
Liberal Arts yep okay okay
and then yeah how did how did you decide
to move there and then how did you
decide with Monroe so Howard different
pop those two jumps so my former coach
and teacher who was actually hired my
senior year was leaving to come down to
Sioux Falls Lincoln and she and I had
been talking for a year better about hey
you know it's just something you want to
do you want to get back in I was I was
still going out in judging so I still
connected to the Speech and Debate
community while I was while I was taking
that year off so that was good um and I
just said yeah I might as well apply and
so I did and they offered it to me and I
said I can go back home my family living
in the area my uncle lived right there
I'm a couple of cousins and in fact I
ended up having their children as my
students I'd
her classmates children as my students I
found out it was related to a whole lot
more people in that town than I thought
I was it was like Oh your mom and my mom
are cousins yeah and your mom and my mom
are cousins and yeah but your mom's my
cousin um you know and that was my first
sophomore class there I think there were
five of them out of 50 they were related
you know when somebody would make some
comment about oh my god I said oh your
life could be worse you could be one of
these people that's related to me and
they're like oh yeah
so yeah in fact that year the senior
English class that I taught about month
two months in the boys decided they were
gonna get brave enough to ask me how old
I was
mmm yeah because that's always that how
old are you and I said you know we're
talking and I said man you know you can
guess and they guessed some age that was
so not even close they were way low and
one of the girls was like raising her
hand and I said he asked
she just didn't you graduate with my mom
listen yeah they did or mom was seven
months pregnant when we got when we
walked across the stage she now teaches
down here in Sioux Falls
mmm has two little kids in fact her son
was born the same day as my daughter
talk about weird connections but her mom
and I started reconnecting we weren't
friends in high school we knew each
other we weren't unfriendly but and she
sent my parents a letter probably my
dad's been gone about six years now so
probably two eight ten years ago sends
him a letter and said I just want you to
know how thankful I am that the two of
you didn't let me quit because back in
1980-81 you didn't finish school if he
were if you were pregnant and my parents
sat down with her and said you have to
do this what can we do to help I didn't
know that I didn't know they've done
that for her yeah you know something's
like yep that would be my parents I
don't know why I didn't think that but
that's what happened
in inchi and I talked to she goes I just
I just want you to know I say your dad
mom this letter and and I can't do
anything but thank them and then I
thought wait a minute I'm not the only
one that helped strays you know it's a
family thing I mean it is with you big
heart big hearts definitely and then sir
than the pool to Roosevelt then how did
that happen so when I was at dual and
clear like I was coaching aural and her
I was coaching debate and I was also
directing three shows oh wait plus I had
a full-time job called teaching I was to
the point where my body was falling
apart physically I had a doctor say
what's going on
somes gotta give that was it it was just
it was too much because I also wasn't
getting the supports I needed from my
administration and now that and I just
said my health is more important as much
as I don't want to leave here I mean I
didn't buy one year I mean duels is a
school of 200 in the high school wait
five kids at a national tournament when
you're going up against Watertown in
Aberdeen Central and Milbank which is a
powerhouse at the time and here on and
all of those well ones we were going up
against I mean it wasn't in Brookings I
mean it wasn't like we were punking out
and just getting lucky we were we were
working our Fannie's off and I had an
administrator who because his football
team wasn't being successful he was mad
it's like okay you're gonna be jealous
because these kids are having advantages
and every one of those five kids is
doing unbelievable things right now mmm
unbelievable they're all over the
they're all over the country yeah yeah
awesome I know and I just and I still
keep in touch with all of them and yeah
that's what top-tier Speech and Debate
really do I think yeah I think they do
that exciting one's an engineer one is
an administrator at a school down in the
Twin Cities now and that's not where she
started but you know Hearst was
once you HR for you know medical and one
is out North Carolina still go on a grad
school and and doing amazing things
there just yeah ones out in the LA area
from dual like something that's a those
are old massive jumps yeah yeah duals
how how big again inside people maybe mm
yeah see that so that's a big deal to to
go out because every single one of those
people when they say where they're from
the other people will be like yeah I've
never heard of that place
yeah yeah yeah okay so okay so back to
this
yeah transition to yeah Rosa so I knew
there was an opening at Roosevelt I also
knew that I didn't know if I wanted to
go to a school of that size and still be
involved
I was really this is a big really bring
you were burned out and this is a big
jump seer
yeah you're so the school where you were
teaching at was how many hundred kids
209 school two hundred in high school
and this is an order of magnitude bigger
2,000 kids and like so it's a big deal
Roosevelt High School at the time if you
counted staff students anybody that
worked there was about the same size as
the town I came yeah that's crazy and if
I mean I said that the kids are like
what is it yeah people actually live in
those places it's okay yeah and they
have smarts and they have good things
going on and they have it it's okay you
know but that was culture shock for them
to know that I had been you know so it's
kind of cool is the size of a city yeah
which is kind of what you get with these
bigger not public universities as well
better how I say no thank you
students coming in tomorrow you know so
it is crazy but there are so many things
that are so much the same no matter
where you go okay so what were your
excitements reservations as you're okay
so coming here I had within the year
prior finished my masters in
administration so I was really looking
for administration jobs I was ready to
move to that level follow my dad's
footsteps yada
all of that so Sioux Falls had an
opening at the district level for a fine
arts coordinator I went hello this seems
like a good so I applied for that so I
didn't apply for the teaching job right
away
in fact it was July when I had my
interview they had already gone through
a whole cycle of interviews and turned
everybody down hmm
so I came in and at the time we're also
it was looking for someone and the
Washington coach was taking a one-year
sabbatical I interviewed of both places
on the same day mm-hmm and I mean I
didn't even get ten minutes away from
the last interview and I got a call from
the Human Resources and said which one
do you want yeah take the one-year do I
want to take you know the one that I
know is gonna be around for a while well
not knowing the culture of the Sioux
Falls School District and openings that
might be available in the following year
it's like I don't want to be hung with
just a one-year position and I got to
turn around do all this all over a
course yeah so and young man who had
been my assistant up into all was trying
to get into the system too and had been
turned down for some reason there was
some black mark on his information
because they had they had said hey yeah
we're really interested in hiring you
and then IPC said yeah no you're not and
they got their hands slept and whatever
so I was keeping in contact with him the
whole time I said I I said let me let me
think about this and I'll get back to
you called him and said okay here's the
deal
you me these two positions need filling
mm-hmm if I take the roosevelt job you
can call the principal at washington and
you know that principal because he had
connections serious his kids and stuff
from college and say look this is a
one-year gig and it's it's even a
part-time gig i can take care of your
program for a year and so he went to bat
then at IPC and said look this is the
only guy that's out there yeah so both
of us came in the same year we're both
still here
great oh he's still there too he's now
teaching AP econ and yeah he made the
sleeping great breakfast you know he had
a PF team that made fourth in the nation
had Amin so go so why he's been very
successful as well as teaching wise he's
been successful though it's a huge you
know it's like you got to get this guy
another chance yeah you know because
he's students how while he was teaching
full-time yeah because they needed a
teacher and they hired him on and in
another town and I think that's where
the problem came in because he really
struggled he didn't have anybody
mentoring him so when they got him you
know when he got here he said here's
what I need from you I need this
mentoring I need these things to happen
so give us an idea of what this has been
like then let's go ahead and let's go
ahead and do it with the Roosevelt days
and you can even you know spar sent a
little bit of the earlier days as well
along the way but really these you know
this last decade plus of of taking what
you've been learning in Speech and
Debate
teaching that oral interpreting that
language arts in dealing with all the
like unique learning styles of the
students dealing with the the addition
of technology into the classrooms what
has been like how do you you know take a
big
field like speech or debate and how do
you even like synthesize it into a prep
like for a class oh yeah walking through
this so with any kind of speaking just
like any kind of writing just kind of
you're doing a science experiment what
there are component parts so you have to
look at those pieces I mean I say the
kids okay so you've seen a speech before
you've seen somebody talk you get it now
let's look at the pieces and let's break
it down you know you look at an
introduction what information are they
giving you in that little itty bitty
piece that leads to the the main
structure of the body that then gives
you all this knowledge and then how do
they wrap it up how do they tie those
ends together at the very end we take
something like a great speech and then
we begin breaking it down into its
components how did they make the intro
how do they make the body how in their
conclusion how do they wrap it all
together to make it so that they were
able to communicate something of great
knowledge and just pass it along to
someone else
okay so then this is then the listen the
processes then how do you get then
students to then do things like go
through that process themselves with
topics they actually want to talk about
or sometimes you have to also give them
yeah okay yes how does the see how this
process works so years ago I stole from
somebody else because that's what good
teachers do we steal from each other and
we readily admit it a stall that from
you and I and I really like it's it's
three phases if you break up a speech
and to tell them what you're gonna tell
them tell them and then tell them what
you told them then they're gonna come
away with the stuff that you want them
to have okay
so kid what is it you want to share what
do you want them to know find that
information now let's get that organized
and now let's go back and get that
introduction to set it up so that people
are gonna hear you because if you just
start talking and you haven't set them
up they're not sure what to listen for
so teaching them that they have to guide
just like they would if they're writing
a paper it's truly important and then
finish it up you know I tell them it's
like a good burger
mmm and you get the patty in there but
if you forget one of the buns it's kind
of messy me
there's open-faced sandwiches and
they're not bad but you can't hold them
in your hand they're not concise so you
know I do all that kind of drawing on
the board and that kind of stuff and of
course they find out I'm not artistic
and it's okay it's okay I readily admit
it because we all have our strengths so
just being able to to get them in and I
try to use examples from their personal
life you know when we start talking
about how do you incorporate evidence
mm-hmm how many of you have said to
someone my mom just said to me or my dad
told me no like well yeah you just
incorporated evidence with a source yes
so we do that everyday I said so and it
remind them that what we're doing is if
things we do every day notice or we're
just giving it a name yeah we're just
labeling the plots you come home and you
witness someone out of your parent a co
house school you're a medially giving a
speech you're doing a story right away
oh my gosh this is the craziest day in
my life this listen this happened so
when this happened but it absolutely we
do it yeah it's organized it's planned
out but we don't think about it so now I
wanna make them think about it I think
we would think what Oh but stop thinking
so hard pull those pieces together even
to get them to frame an outline in
outline format Roman numerals and
capital letters with it look on their
face like are you talking about and then
I start showing them that the whole
wedding clustering thing well you just
put circles and you draw lines to
connect and they're like well yeah I
don't want to do that yeah and then I
start drawing on their the Roman
numerals and capital letters yeah Oh
take what you know and then move it
forward yeah that's true with anything
you do in life
you know as a little kid you watch mom
and dad drive the car and you might have
a little something that you drive and
sooner or later you're gonna get behind
the wheel and you know all of that
memory all of those things we've learned
along the way in education we call it
pride in our knowledge we use that so I
try to find those common link things to
help students and then how does the
student then get over some of the fear
of delivering speeches so I tell them
there's always gonna be butterflies you
put me in front of my peers my
butterflies are going you put me in a
situation like this and you and I are
just talking it's you and I just talking
I'm okay you put me in front of a
classroom of students not a big deal
that's that's what I do every day but if
you put me in front of all those speech
in debate you know I still get the
butterflies it's okay as long as you
know how to use them to your advantage
mm-hmm you take that energy and you know
maybe you got to make something really
big so you can throw them out of there
so just talking to them about gestures
and movement body language and those
kinds of things to let them know how do
you how do you use it how do you get
over it and the key is if you're
organized if you've planned ahead if
you're prepared ahead you are calmer
because you know what you want to say
you're not going in going what am I
going to talk about it you know you're
just kind of weirding yourself out okay
yeah yeah we know we were talking
yesterday and I was telling her all this
stuff and I was telling my friend Ellis
yeah you know what you want to say now
just do it mnemonic techniques helped a
lot the memory palace yes things like
that yeah and then they also tell them
you know especially for those that just
kind of like yeah you know the Raceway
speeches slow down and breathe because
the ticket second you take that slow
cleansing breath and then you let it out
slowly you any of us can feel our heart
rate slowed down yeah that in turn slows
down how fast you're gonna talk and if
you need to do that in the middle of a
speech
find a place in your hearts even if
you're still talking you can still do it
so just teaching in those little tricks
that are you know that should hopefully
become second nature to them yeah and I
tell them you know in the beginning if I
start talking too fast you have to let
me know because I don't know it you know
you can't you debate for how many years
plus I was a debater myself plus my mom
said I came out the second I started
talking it was at the fastest rate you
know so I've been talking about since I
was a little kid evidently sometimes I
need people that slow me down one of my
first years of teaching I had a foreign
exchange student in my class and she
dropped the class and I was like what
happened
she just went so fast they said oh how
much do is tell me to slow down mm-hmm
and then you know I started the hallways
and she and I talked I'll Dom the rest
of the year and stuff and she's like how
I should have stayed and I wish I'd have
known that so I now make that very clear
right I mean that was a learning
experience for me too I was I was just a
kid in and at the point - so how does
the decision to to give a students a
topic versus let them freestyle their
own topics come so to be honest I don't
just say here's your topic I will give
them a pool yeah of topics so I have
speech that I've been doing for several
years and it's musicians who have made
great change that has led to where we
are today well it's it's musicians from
the 50s 60s and 70s and the further we
get away from that the closer we still
are because that music is right out
there you know you go to any CSI show
and that music is from the 50s 60s and
70s
yeah and some of those artists are still
out there I mean how many concerts we've
had here in town that have been those
people and it's amazing because that
songs on Shrek or that songs on you know
they're hearing it in movies and it's
like you didn't even realize this was
this band you didn't realize this was
this soloist and and so it makes them
think about
even though that was 6070 years ago some
of it
it's a pertinent today they still did
things I mean you're not finding the
stuff from the 90s that's getting
repeated now but you are finding stuff
in 50s 60s 70s that keeps getting him a
dream girlz was just done Mamamia is all
that music from then I keep going I mean
it's just it keeps coming back because
it was good solid music and it makes
them look at that okay so but what did
these groups do or what are these
individuals do that
who's the precursor to rap who's the
precursor to you know who is the first
one that did the big arena concerts
months from that era so I you know as
much as they go once they start getting
into it and listening to the music and
realizing oh my gosh you know there's
only some of them that are like oh my
parents listen to that others do it all
the time that's a grand stuff in the
world I don't know or do all this yeah
let's not let's find some of the other
Ellis is on the list but you know so but
it's fun it's there's there's an
embedded educational or evolutionary
ethical moral spiritual lesson that's
embedded in the topics that you give
them in this one and they kind of get to
figure out what those lessons are
themselves as they do their research and
give them the speeches but it's really
cool to have it be about something like
the evolution of consciousness and how
much more aware or more towards light
that we became from these great musical
leaders yeah and they're like why isn't
this group on there wasn't this group
yeah I was like why isn't Queen on there
well Queen did some amazing things but
there were other people that were
already doing it you know you talk about
the whole rock opera and the
storytelling and you're talking meatloaf
he was there first so that's his on the
list let's break down the different
styles of speech so like oil
interpretation extemporaneous speaking
original oratory in
motive which includes visual aids I
remember doing extemporaneous speaking
and that was a lot about finding
evidence and then just going and giving
a talk on specific evidence-based topic
what are the differences between you
knows I actually never did oral
interpret I thought it was quite
interesting to take the different
beautiful narratives or pieces that had
been written and be able to add your own
interpretive style tooth or toria
delivery so extent what you did
extemporaneous its current events you
know what's going on in the world or
what's going on here right here in the
US you get a question and you have to
answer it but again it's that
introduction body conclusion there it is
little domestic or international way you
could pick still yeah you to pick stuff
yes that's absolutely true okay yeah and
the but the question is for how long is
the question a year or how long is it
just fit tournament is the question
right because that question list every
tournament has a question every question
list comes so the best you can do to
prep for that is to pay attention to the
news mm yeah so you're watching the news
you're reading the news you're
organizing and then and then you're
filing some of those articles so you can
go back to look at them and then those
same marks now that when electronically
you remember you you get it all on
Google Drive or whatever they can just
store that that's very interesting
compared to what we had with the big
tubs of stuff and so it's cool that they
can then take what they did for speech
with current events and they can then
apply that to their public forum or
policy debates Lincoln Oaks the base
right yeah it can be that crossover
crossover okay and it teaches you a
different kind of speaking style yeah
which comes in handy sometimes to a
single versus a team link with yep Oh
foreign policy right and a different way
of using evidence yeah you know yeah
when you're using evidence to beat your
point home the other you're using
evidence as a support mmm so one
evidence drives it the other one the
evidence is not right
yeah so oral interpretation one of the
best ways to to explain it to people is
it's like reading a book to a little kid
mm-hmm and if you start doing Goldilocks
and the three bears and you're like and
the three bears came in the house and
they got scared no little kids gonna
listen to you they're gonna be screaming
they're gonna be pounding they're gonna
be doing whatever going that's not right
but if you're like and Goldilocks walked
in and realized she was really hungry
and and and she smelled the porridge and
it smelled so good so she tried it and
in the first bowl she tried was a lot
and you're using your whole body and
you're using your voice and this is just
right in the bed and they chair and then
and then the Bears come in and go oh
well bears are gone they're broken and
you know a mom and dad you're going
where the heck's going on in our house
that's gonna it's bringing it to life
and it doesn't matter if it's a piece of
poetry if it's a children's book if it's
a narrative like you're talking about
any of those things it can be a play it
can be in prose form it can be serious
it can be humorous there's there's so
many choices bringing it to life is the
key yes yeah without changing your
authors intent if you take a novel and
you only have ten minutes to present I
don't know too many novels that are
gonna fit in that 10 minutes nobody
talks that fast
not even debaters great so you have to
you have to cut what we call cutting and
you find that story within the story and
you tell that story yeah so maybe it's
you know maybe it's a main character
maybe it's a minor character but you
like the story that's being told about
it and you just focus on that and you
bring that out mm-hmm so there's some
traces that have to be made and then
physically you have to you know I'm like
if you're gonna be drinking out of a
glass on the sea drink out of glass and
your thumb better not be here on your
face and you need to make it realistic
so it's all pan amount as well so that's
it's fun
yeah and then besides individually you
can do it as a duo you can have a
partner but one of the two rules that
kind of throw it to make it not acting
you cannot physically touch and you
cannot have direct eye contact
interesting yeah so you look over each
other's shoulder so it looks like you're
looking at each other but you can't
actually look yeah if something sad you
can't have tears coming down you can't
bring them right to the edge
oh but they're not supposed to drop
because that's acting interesting so
it's it's that fine line okay yeah I
know costumes and makeup you can just
stick you late but you can't like start
performing like really physically all
over the stage you do some can't
cartwheel on [ __ ] there have been people
who have done some of that or drop to
their knees or that's okay right but for
you I'll make a hug but neither one was
touching each other okay interesting
okay so you can't go into acting that's
that's cool right yeah yeah okay so okay
so do what we Aikido trio or quartet can
you know do you do all or in South
Dakota we have a thing called reader's
theater which is three to six people
yeah cool yeah so they're fun too okay
and those they can actually write their
own if they want to so I've worked with
students one time we took dr. Seuss and
ii think you saw it on Mulberry Street
and then we took other dr. Seuss books
it was right around the time of the OJ
Simpson trials I mean since how long ago
it's been and we even threw in something
about gloves we put the whole glove not
fitting and I mean so we brought in pop
culture as well but we all these little
pieces you know the foot book was in
there and the end we just everybody
picked brought their favorite one and we
worked as a team to put pieces together
we sat on my living room floor and went
keep it don't keep it too you know and
it had a blast not what I have that
group on my living room floor now 27
years later no we're gonna stay at
school
where there's cameras in the hallway
where there's and and that's something
that's changed that that is really too
bad
whoa you can't take well to practice
outside of them what happens if
something happens in my home and who's
to say it happened or it didn't happen
we live in a whole different world than
waited 27 years ago you know those
parents were like oh your girl's great
call me when you're ready to go home or
at least let me know when you're on your
way home no big deal everybody brought
snacks meat soda
yeah we worked for three hours and that
was after we had practice that's cool
yeah so it's nine ten o'clock - let my
house Wow how fast things
yeah changed to a more big brother yeah
I love existence yeah because we've
become so litigious it's like oh you're
gonna put a lawsuit on me oh okay you
know I mean people have lost their jobs
because somebody said well something
happened nothing happened but you were
mad at that person so you said it there
it is
that doesn't go away okay we'll talk
more about these differences in a little
bit okay original oratory and
informative original oratory an
informative are both student rid hmm so
they do the research they pick the topic
they do it original oratory is
persuasive mm-hmm and so quite often it
becomes a problem solution but it can be
a here just going on in the world where
are we gonna go from here kind of
concept to so that one's kind of fun
because I mean you soup-to-nuts
everything is possible
same thing with important if you pick a
topic and they do that topic all year at
the term yes why did they write it they
can always they can always tweak it and
do all of that but they stay with that
same speech because they memorize it and
how long would you say then you're given
for an oil interp is as a or eletrobras
a ten minute maximum oratory and
informative or ten minute maximums
extemporaneous is five to seven minutes
minutes yeah and then disloyal interp
like a single performance throughout the
year that I've put together usually
that's stated it
some of them will have two different
pieces they're working on okay yeah
maybe they got your Most Wanted serious
whiner they're in a duo and I solo one
yeah okay so or they're doing an oral
and trippi's and they're doing original
oratory as well because they want to
write their own so they can cross they
can cross all of that so at most with
extemporaneous speaking they're getting
a couple like hours to prepare for their
thirty minutes so here's the question
the question you have 30 minutes when
you're speaking yeah which is why I say
you have to know what's going on in the
world in the world you have to be on top
of the news yeah I mean let that one
then because yeah you're pulling the
card from the evidence about this
article said this from the source yeah
about what's happening hey it's okay
thirty minutes on that one okay this or
those I think original oratory okay and
then let's do a fun informative is
fairly new it just started in the last
four years and it can be again any topic
like I said we had a student from
another school who was walking around
the toilet seat because he was talking
about bathrooms and and how they've
changed and how no that kind of stuff
one young lady was carrying around a
little a little mini coffin because she
was talking about funeral homes and
working in them and doing those kinds of
things
anything's forget any topic and they get
to have those who can't help visual aids
so I mean they can have any moisture
judges they just have them up there with
them also they're using them I can bring
like props of visuals yeah so people
were using a lot of 3d kinds of things
and and you know some use posters and
some use actual items yeah so that
that's so that's nice because now you've
got two very different writing styles in
in persuasive original oratory or in
that informative style you know one
you're just telling about something and
giving people that information the other
one you're trying to pull them to your
side of the issue and get I'm thinking
the way you everything in our for all of
those speech subcategories are they all
being judged by multiple judges and then
the multiple judges are picked
well like a ranked order of like
ascribing which one of the performers
that I give the high score to versus the
second third fourth fifth and then those
scores are congregated so so what will
happen in an in a regular round and a
tournament round is there will be one
judge in the room and then usually not
more than seven competitors and then
that judge has to listen to all of them
write comments to them give them
feedback things that went well things
they can work on and then they have to
rank them one two three four five five
five five okay so quite often we just
stop at five mm-hmm some tournaments now
we're stopping at six some are saying
that just rank them all it's okay
because then those scores the highest
right and then they'll either have two
or three preliminary rounds so they'll
get two or three different judges that
will hear them and then those scores get
tabulated and then the top you know five
six seven will go into a final round
earning the final round there's three
judges in the back of the room okay yep
so it's not just based on one one
person's view of it yeah
I'm actually a little bit I would love
to see more adults especially like in
their 20s like I would have left to
continue like to do and doing
extemporaneous speaking like in San
Francisco and stuff like I would have
loved to see that so I know the one
organization that exists is Toastmasters
yeah and they do have competition yeah
they do
yeah so that's that's one option yeah
yeah that's like yeah you're right
that's that's pretty it's pretty good
that's pretty solid I wish it was more
popular this is a thing like I wish all
of these were available to all ages with
judges that were being like paid and
that there were people that were excited
about about this and that like that this
would help with that whole thing we were
talking about nuance and gray area yeah
because you look beyond yourself whether
it's oral interpreters extent whether
it's original Torrie or inform you have
to look beyond yourself what is it that
I'm trying to bring
the rest of the people here yeah what do
I want them to hear here yeah and it
can't just be my own thoughts I have to
support it yeah okay let's do debate so
okay let's do let's do debate so okay
let's start with policy debate okay
so policy debate is wanting to make a
change in the system that's going on now
okay
just like our you know Congress will
make a policy change don't make a new
law they'll make whatever that's what
policy debate does so look at the area
of climate change okay so what are some
ways we can better handle climate change
that's on the affirmative they want to
make the change the negative says it's
good right now let's just back off you
don't need to make this change status
quo let's keep going where we're at and
they'll argue that back and forth you
know what our advantage is what our
disadvantages you know why why is this a
good idea whether the bad idea and
support it with evidence in multiple
sources for it because if you just get
one source it's like yes so one guy said
that everyone you know one women or one
organization show me there's other
people out there that believe the same
thing back it up and then show me with
scientific evidence I don't just want
some schmuck that's read a book and
decided to tell the whole world what he
thinks I want to have more than that I
want to know that there have been some
studies and some research and those
kinds of things so policy debate really
gets in-depth and through the years it's
been things like Consumer Product Safety
every four years they'll do an
international topic so it's you know
it's China it's Russia it's it's Latin
America it's whatever and it might be
trade or it might be human rights issues
or it might be you know any of those
kinds of things we've done education
we've done military we've done in the
topics kinda start repeating because
there are some really big picture items
hugely that are that are important yes
we can I like I got I got a little
little list of some fur for people yeah
you know what this year's topic is this
year's is the United States federal
government should substantially reduce
direct commercial sales and/or foreign
military sales of arms from the United
States and then the year prior the
United States fell government should
substantially reduce its restrictions on
legal immigration to the United States
prior to that increase its funding and
our regulation of primary and or
secondary education in the United States
and then prior to that was this
international increase its economic and
our diplomatic engagement with the
People's Republic of China substantially
curtailing its domestic surveillance all
these incredibly thought-provoking
topics yeah and there have been people
who have said that the amount of work
that a varsity debater so junior senior
level debater puts in for a topic like
that
is as much or more work than someone who
is doing their PhD dissertation that's
so interesting and these are high school
kids you know 14 15 16 17 18 year olds
who are doing that kind of research and
we wonder why they're becoming leaders
because they get it and they're able to
switch off of an affirmative or negative
haven't been both sides every round they
switch sides so you say should be start
on the firm ative let's say on the first
round and then they would switch to the
negative in the second they'd off the
debate gets the different different team
to you yep yep and they're persuading
three judges same thing with preliminary
rounds of speech you get one judge you
get into a box you get out Rollins or
quite quarters and that kind of stuff
then you'll get three judgments same
thing in public forum and a linkedlist
why two three okay right and so the
negative is basically trying to do their
best to make it so that they keep the
status quo don't listen to what the firm
of saying these are the reasons why from
this an informative is like we need to
transition the nuclear fusion for energy
as soon as possible here is the vast
amount of data and sources that are
saying here's the problems they're going
to create
we're gonna blow up that nuke war
whatever versus the high efficiencies of
it this is why we should do it yeah okay
yeah see this is why I'm really happy
you brought up how it's um it's actually
like as much research goes into this as
even a PhD dissertation I mean can you
believe the more young people and even
adults later in their lives that have to
do that much work to come up with a pro
or con argument on these topics be able
to switch like that's what's gonna get
more nuanced more gray area more
thinking instead of just a simple
cognitive these binary statement about
something yeah and just the skills the
research skills the thought skills
because you also have to ask the other
team questions so you need to come up
with questions on the fly you need to
get those answers on the fly and they
need to be concise they need to be
focused they need to because you're on a
time limit you got three minutes to ask
as many questions as you want to ask
yeah you got eight minutes to present
your speech yeah you got five minutes to
wrap up in your rebuttal they do not
huge amounts of time it's not like
you're getting an hour that's right yeah
you have to you have to do a compression
algorithm on the key points right and
then yeah you also have to you have to
do a flow you have to flow really well
so get good nuts you do you see us so
when you when you do in a census parsing
for the key points that they are saying
writing those down with like
abbreviation so that you don't have to
guys still use you know BC for because
or BW for between or whatever just a w
/r with w / 4 which is weird over
without don't know so yeah use arrows
arrows you know tons of hair toy toward
yeah yeah yeah I love that so so you're
you're really in a sense you're yeah
you're getting really good at like
parsing for key points which is actually
extremely relatable to everything else
that you do like when you're listening
to other people talk to your friends
your family's co-workers your
romantic partners all stuff like do you
know how to listen for a key point and
then ask a question about that key point
which is literally a key to life is like
that right there right then you get
excellent at that through debate right
because you're doing it you know during
practices and you're competing every
weekend and you're you know you're
constantly just improving on yourself
yeah or you'll be in the oh one life
column one day you know everybody else
is gonna kick your Fanny at the
tournament and yeah
what are we win well you didn't work
very hard this week did you yeah what's
the let's talk about the talk about
evidence as well you mention this a
little bit for extent but I just want to
say like this is really interesting that
what you would do is you would take
since whatever you have as evidence and
it used to be interesting because we
would do things like try and like you
use like a Wikipedia as evidence but no
you have to actually look at what we're
Wikipedia citing what size exciting it's
our primary source right and because
Wikipedia is just another encyclopedia
it's a PDF and so okay so then what you
do is you take something and you would
actually like instead of you know have a
big 10 page like you know that'd be a
lot to try and you have to synthesize
that into like a paragraph and that
would be like your little like abstract
about it and then you would though it
was called a tag a site in a body and
like that would be the body and the tag
or maybe be a sentence that's even
synthesizing that and then the site is
where did it come from the citation and
hopefully the tag is reflective of the
body yeah that's some people do we could
refer to as power tagging it's like yeah
they didn't really say what you think it
said nice try though yeah read that line
again no that's not what it says that's
funny because that is actually really
applicable to the mainstream media right
now where these tags these headlines are
just click Beatty and the bodies don't
even any department
yeah I was like what are we doing people
debate is so important it's like
something that like it should be require
it's a speech or debate is that only a
semester it's only a semester require
required but we're one of the few states
in the nation that still require it what
do you mean like literally they do drop
in or less states that still require it
10 or west states require just the
semester in high school so it was there
at one point when all 50 states where I
don't know if all 50 were but a lot more
work yeah and why do they ever have
why are like the humanities and language
arts taking the toll that they well when
when Common Core came in there was talk
here in South Dakota about well they've
got the speech component already built
in so we really don't need it anymore we
should just get rid of it this is the
State Department of Ed was talking this
well we got wind of it and went back the
train up cuz you're wrong and even the
English teachers were like we don't have
we don't have time to deal with the
curriculum we have right now
no because it's it's the repetitiveness
you know they do a speech we talk about
what they did what went right what were
I wrong
now let's find another topic and let's
try again and we have 18 weeks to do
that whereas and you know this even with
writing you got six weeks to write a
research paper of whatever sort in a
class okay I'm also not just teaching
them how to stand up in front of people
and get the words out of their mouth and
teaching them how to outline I'm
teaching them how to use evidence and
how to incorporate that in and all of
those things and now they can take those
skills into that six weeks in that
English class and they don't have to
take as much time to teach it there
because these kids already know it and
you want to get rid of this big
yeah we don't think it's a good idea so
many of us wrote into the state because
they had a time where we could make
comments and that's well that's been
several years ago now one comic art
which was coming out and we haven't
heard anything since yeah it's great
that even the English teachers were like
whoa whoa whoa we can add that and plus
we don't that's a that's a critical life
requirement or skill that we don't teach
in our English classes that so it's
actually something that I mean if I was
to again if I was to you know be someone
that could make a request would be treat
debate and speech like it's a serious
life skill which it is literally like
speaking persuasion synthesizing I have
evidence note-taking pursuing all these
types of things are just they're so
critical and nuanced gray area of being
able to switch between the pro and con I
mean those are such a critical thing so
instead of a semester let's make it a
year and instead of a year let's make it
a lifelong thing where you're like
frequently going through these processes
that's in a sense that's that's what
besides featuring all the different
leaders in their fields like we do on
this show you know I'm also synthesizing
what these hundreds of people are
teaching us on the show into some sort
of a cool relatable presentations along
the way in these and then eventually
multimedia content all different types
of things and so it's it's so applicable
to life and it's just like can we make
it more popular when we're adults to to
be doing these types things like could
you pick up a complex project like
healthcare and could you then go and
look at you know dozens of books and
peer-reviewed papers and all these types
of things about about the way that we do
health care in the future of healthcare
and how to most optimally meet those
requirements from people and and paint
some sort of strategic next steps on how
to best do that like in fact how much
more of a well-rounded person would you
be if you did that so it's just like
it's like common sense but it's
it in many ways like what was going on
in the Agora days and the Greek days or
there's just more of this like Socratic
dialogue that was occurring and now it's
so interestingly and this is a great
example I there there's not a college
that I'm aware of that doesn't require
at least a semester of speech and the
vocational schools the tech schools have
all you know junior colleges over the
con now have all gone to the same thing
you have to at least take a semester we
had a young lady several years ago that
came back on one of her breaks and was
in an Ivy League school on the East
Coast and said you would not believe my
classmates and some of my friends who
went to Ivy League prep schools who were
panicking during speech class because
they didn't know what to do yeah and she
said little old me from South Dakota it
was like I got this speech was easy and
they're like what did you do she's like
I had taken high school yeah like what
species over didn't right you know so
unless you unless and those skills
lecture on Speech and Debate team you
don't get it yeah so you know she was
feeling pretty good I was like good for
you you deserve to feel that way about
it cuz you took those skills in that you
got from here and I tell my students
that now this is what I heard from
someone who went to an Ivy League school
I swear whispered I swear that looking
back how you can connect dots more
easily about your life outcomes in your
life trajectory I swear Speech and
Debate is just like one of the biggest
pillars in the bedrock of altering my
life trajectory in a more positive
direction even the days you and I bought
it up even when we butted heads because
that was you learning to it was
absolutely yeah yep you know and I knew
that going into teaching it searching
it's like my butt heads with some these
kids yes and I would tell you I've had
kids who are a lot smarter than me
who had no common sense so I tried to
fill in that for them and said you're on
the right track here's the skills you
need you take that brain of yours and
just run with it
now I out care if you're smarter than me
I always know I should work with people
who are smarter than me they'll make me
look good right so yeah I love the way
that something like a Speech and Debate
like butterflies effect butterfly
effects out like you're thousands of
students that you've had the chance to
to teach have now went on the Yugi were
giving so many other examples earlier
it's just like teaching is so rich in
that sense of like passing along really
so solid like students being able to
come back and just be like thank you so
like the letter to my parents it was
20-some years later
yeah it's one years later it's a long
term delayed gratification don't even
expect the letter but when they come
it's like wow yeah yeah yeah yeah the
cool thing about content like this is
that also we actually literally have
people commenting on the videos and
saying things like wow that was so
interesting or that altered this thing
for me and my towns and it's cool
because you get like a faster feedback
cycle but there could be something cool
like a piece of content that lives on
for a really long time and then impacts
people down the line let's talk about
the other styles as well so there's
lincoln-douglas debate in point form
debate so it didn't get noses only one
that has a one-on-one anybody this is
one-on-one and it is more philosophical
so it's it's asking art we do this you
know when in conflict which one is the
higher value mmm so you get the
Philosopher's you get valued level
debates those kinds of things and that
just started in the early 80s so that's
in a lot of ways still in its infancy
we'll call that the toddler mmm because
public forum has only been around for
about 10 15 ish years there's the infant
it's baby yeah and it has changed
because it was Ted Turner debates
because he gave a bunch of money and
sponsored it and then it will mean so
it's had a couple of different names and
even now they're talking about changing
the the layout of it and changing how
much time for for the different portions
of it what do they want to do whatever
change they want to make
well what's happening it's a public
forum topic wise first of all yes is
something that's that's in the news now
so and open up a newspaper or listen to
a news show whatever and if it's
something that's a big thing that's
something that could be in there we have
more had those as well I mean what one
time it was the NBA dress code and do
they have a right to tell these people
who are making millions of dollars how
to dress well the question is do you
work for me or don't you work for me oh
I mean I can't go to work in my swimsuit
and throw a pair of shorts on yeah there
are things that I know professionally I
should be doing so the question was can
you have your pants saggin and you know
all the metal on you and and look I'm
like you're a gangbanger and go out and
do an interview when you're representing
our team yeah yeah yeah so it's those
kinds of things that's interesting yeah
that's a really interesting one yeah in
just the last just last year was the
United States federal government should
impose price controls on the
pharmaceutical industry and then a
couple months prior to that was the
unicity should a seat to the United
Nations Convention on the law of the sea
without reservations United abolished
capital gains tax Spain should grant
Catalonia its independence Unites States
ought to replace electoral college with
the direct national popular vote
Mace's Farrell governor should adopt a
carbon tax testings benefit standardized
testings beneficial to the K through 12
education system unit eight so these are
the kind of the topics right and it's
usually what's going on there and that
was changed every month yeah
every month every month doing nothing is
deep as you are with policy debate which
is one topic for the year for the entire
year right and some of those kids go to
camp in the summer and they start
researching in June for tournaments who
don't start until November yeah so
they're working lincoln-douglas changes
every two months so it's off the corner
they'll do two different topics and
perform the next four four or five five
topics yeah yeah and then and is
supposed to focus toward late judges so
anybody walking on the street we should
be able to pull them in and they should
be able to judge it and is that usually
the judge that is late
that is the goal so you can literally
get like a letter to your mom pop can
come as I tell them if we're a shorter
judge we're gonna go grab the custodian
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he lives in
society - and these are societal topics
exactly yeah
interesting yes should be geared more
towards the lay whereas maybe policies
geared more towards Congress style of
like PFF
more trained judges more trained judges
right right they understand the style
and they understand the different
argument types and that kind of thing
yeah yeah okay and yeah there's a
difference as some differences in the
style for lincoln-douglas about reform
versus policy but highly recommend those
that either are in the current
educational system to please get in with
all this feature debate or even those
that are parents and listening please
get the children involved in this future
debate or if you are adults find a way
to get involved with speech and debate
please your schools to support it and
get schools to support it yeah you know
let's also talk about the relationship
that you've had with source or with God
or with the divine what has been your
relationship with that through your
years
I grew up going to church and and being
a part of that and it still is very much
a part of my life I believe I don't have
control in this world in a in a look at
my personal life in you know people are
like wow you're 56 years old you have a
four year old and I've gotten the point
now where I look at them and saying you
know what God called and I answered I
didn't think I was going to have a child
of my own
I you know I life had my body had said
no and it and everything else
in fact my husband and I will have our
10th anniversary coming up here in
November so we have been together that
long and we were already in our mid 40s
when we met so divine intervention
absolutely absolutely my daughter is an
amazing human being and her birth mom
was not in a position to to take care of
her in the way that she really wanted to
and so she made a very selfless decision
and when we met her she said I'm really
happy having met you and you're the ones
I want to raise her and we had five
weeks to prepare to have a baby in her
house and I got things from my mother
like you're too old and I finally said
to her here's the deal I didn't make
this phone call this phone call came to
me and I said besides that guarantee me
a 27 year old it's going to be alive in
10 years guarantee me any of us are
because there are no guarantees you know
accidents happen and health issues
happen and we all deal with that and it
happens when it happens and I mean my
mom's 83 years old and she's doing
pretty darn good you know my my dad's
mom was almost 98 years old when she
passed my mom's dad was 92 I think I'm
gonna be around a little while I got
good stuff going on both sides you know
so if I take care of myself my
daughter's got that chance
and so I mean to me that's that's huge
and I guess my connection my strongest
connection with church has been music I
love the old hymns
I you know in fact I sing that in my
daughter and she said what's that song
what's that song mom singing again you
know and it's it's really brought me
back because I all the new hymnals all
of that and they've taken out some of
those really
songs that are really deeply meaningful
to me in fact I have my grandmother's
old hymn book and it's just the it's
just the words it's not even the because
it's the little ones they would carry to
church and somebody would play and they
just knew the words were there and they
went and I so I flipped your pages some
nights and I'll just start singing to
her and it's gotten to the point where
where she sings with me and you know she
wants to do that so yeah that's just
been them thankfully I met a man that
that believes as strongly as I do that
you know this is I mean I joke about my
modern-day family I got my husband on
the Internet and my daughter from a
phone call it happens you know it
happens the way it's supposed to happen
I didn't have any power in it I just
said hey we'll check this out and see
what happens and that's where my life
happened you know so yeah I really
believe that in a and I hope as I'm
walking through my life as an educator
and as just a human being and a mom that
that is being reflected to other people
that that's who I am but I believe that
giving back and loving people for who
they are and where they are and helping
them to grow and become who they are
they're gonna be that's because I've got
the power behind me not because I'm
doing it so yeah
and I struggle because I have a niece
right now that just she's not believing
and she's really having a hard time and
in fact last spring a classmate friend
of hers in the sixth grade committed
suicide and I found out that she was
also contemplating so that's been really
hard cuz before I got married him before
I lived you know very close to them and
she was my girl and I feel like I've let
her down so that was a hard one for me
right now so I you know I make comments
like she was watching my daughter the
other day I said you know why we don't
have all the answers
and we don't know yeah you said but
don't close your mind to it
yeah I'm not gonna push it on her so I'm
just gonna say that yeah it's like don't
close your mind of the possibility that
that's true I may use my daughter as an
example to her said she wouldn't be here
if it wasn't you know there's only so
much you can do so but but my students
are like that too I just you gotta love
them more there yeah and help them love
themselves yeah and I and I I probably
say it every day in my classroom I love
all of you yeah I do not always like you
but I love all of you yeah what do you
think you just did something really dumb
I don't like that yeah well I love you
you're a big girl you know you're human
being that I can handle being around
would you stop doing the dumb stuff yeah
yeah whoo cuz I know we get we have
students who don't hear that at home
yeah the I love yeah absolutely yeah
yeah in that they have this beautiful
gift that they can bring to the world
it's about you know finding what is that
gift
remembering what is that gift otherwise
then those meaningless thoughts can take
over does it feel like the that this is
all a big creative expression of source
or god of creation what I do because it
does everything feel like that does it
feel like we're all bringing our gifts
forth like paint strokes on the canvas
yes and no because I think the people
that don't have that spirituality that
don't have that belief I think if you if
you don't if that's not part of you I
don't I don't think that comes true mmm
you know those people who are just like
yep life is life and mmm rocks whatever
the people who truly have that I think
that it comes out in that in that you
know obviously that worries me for those
people that don't do I think they still
have possibility absolutely you know I
would never give up on anyone did
there's just so much I mean anything any
one of us does is a stroke but which
sides are coming from you know is it
coming from the side of of blessing or
is it coming from the side of of evil
and enforce because those forces both
live in the world
yeah purposely only family then we fight
them every day they make creation
gorgeous yeah yeah yeah yeah would you
say that the what would you say is the
meaning of life
maximizing creativity consciousness
maximizing experience
that's it that's yeah I guess being your
best self and in putting forth the best
you can to make the hole a better this
is really the thing because if I can if
I can put my my best self forward and
that then benefits you and benefits you
it's that butterfly effect it really is
anytime I can give up myself I'm getting
back as much as I'm giving if not more
and as long as I keep believing that you
know I mean I tell my students I'm gonna
learn from you as much as you're gonna
win for me I don't sit in that classroom
thinking I'm the only one that knows
anything because I'm not I have learned
from anyone who's walked in my life and
and that to me is the key it's it's
being open to that open to giving and
open to receiving because the second you
could close yourself off either
direction somebody's losing out well
that you were the person with you yeah
yeah
does it feel like the that spirit comes
to meet the body for school well I'm not
sure which asking me as in does it feel
like spirit meets the body who doesn't
feel like consciousness biologically
emerges from the evolution and then does
it feel like this process is kind of
like that spirit or consciousness coming
for school on earth to bring certain
gifts forth have lessons learning
experiences this type of thing
yeah I think anytime you open yourself
up again to that giving to others well
there's my knowledge that I give out
when I'm teaching or I sit with a
student who's struggling on a personal
level or you know whatever I had a young
lady who came to me a few years ago and
she said you know I don't know what's
going on I'm just about six months clean
and I'm about to get my six month
medallion and my dad and my brother I'm
questioning if they're still clean and
that's why I'm living with and that's
what I'm dealing with and and it's a
month until school's out and she's gonna
graduate and I any looked her straight
in the eye and I said what do you need
from me
I said you're 18 years old you are gonna
make this decision I'm not going to call
in and say hey look she's in a tough
place if you tell me you need a place to
stay I will help you find that place and
and and it should preface the whole
conversation with you're one of the few
people in this building I feel like I
can talk to you so creating those
relationships is as much of what I do
every day as it is telling him how to
give a speech yes and I've had those
similar kind of conversations throughout
my 27 years I have so then the idea
would be then there's the theory that
would be like would if you're
potentially one of your spirits have
literally voiced that prior to
incarnated into these bodies and
literally have decided that that that
discussion was going to have been had
and that you were going to be really
important rules in each other's lives
and you didn't even know about it until
that point oh yeah I believe that
there's so much that's predisposed and
we don't know it's coming I mean we're
doing our thing and we're making the
best choices and the best decisions and
doing all of that
but there's still stuff that's gonna
happen that it's like oh yeah
that was supposed to happen yeah my
daughter was supposed to happen I
conversation was like young lady was
supposed to happen I mean there's so
many things in my life that I go didn't
see that coming but there was and it was
important it was valuable
what would you you just say about us
being in a simulation like somebody's
pulling all the cords and we're really
puppets kind of thing there's a lot uh
to put it on maybe that uh alien species
is testing out things on us we've all
that we've potentially already went to
the point of evolution to the most
complex thing and then we basically
embedded another source within and so
here we are just evolving as you know so
do I believe I lived another life maybe
we'd be more like do you believe that
what is occurring right now is reality
what is reality is it no there are days
when I question reality don't we up here
I do believe it's reality I just in in
the nature of some things that happen
it's like yet nobody could have planned
that no nobody could have thought of
that whether it's something somebody
says whether it's something somebody
does right I mean this whole
conversation it's very organic I don't
think anybody planned out you were gonna
ask what I was gonna say what yeah I'm
okay no I think it's just happening in
the moment mm-hmm what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world
my daughter but just that whole
evolution of life you know that the
cradle to the grave and then that
process just continues on and on and on
yes my daughter's got my grandmother's
name
why just I just wanted to honor my
grandmother you know I mean those kinds
of things and I think that that keeps
those people alive in our memories and
then our you know in our world because
she was a huge part of my life and I
think we just do that I mean you look at
at so many people and that you know a
lot of those older names are coming back
now and it's very interesting because
it's like yep that's a family name yep I
want to keep that one going yet by
hunting you know with me it was not
necessarily oh it's a family name it was
it can't be a name that son I've ever
been on a student list because I don't
want my child to have to live up to or
live down something that someone who was
a student of mine ever did I want her to
have her own future in her own you know
and then look to those things because my
husband and I laughed about that we were
coming up with names because the first
mom let us name her and he starts
rattling off all these names and he was
teaching at the time and I said will you
please stop I said where are you getting
these names I was just thinking through
my class list I said you have to stop
I've been I've been teaching for 20-some
years and this was got no thought can I
open it he's like why you don't even
teach in 34 years said I have heard all
these names I can tell you who all these
people are in fact I can tell you
multiple people who were these you know
because they've had the same name so
that was part of that o process of of
coming up with a name and and collective
to say who is this child to us yeah yeah
yeah so I mean it was kind of fun
multiple people with the same name I can
tell those five I've had that versus
hurry up with something so unique or
also
coming up with something that's in the
familial lineage yeah yeah I mean I
wasn't going with Jennifer yeah by the
time I was a senior in high school that
was the most popular female baby name
yeah yeah there are very many of my age
but boy there's a whole lot of them that
are younger yeah I got tired of hearing
it you know so yeah I just wanted
something that was damn get as unique of
a name as possible well doesn't mean you
spelled it funny Thanks Epson a name you
don't need to put 12 Z's you don't need
to know unique unique identity and your
name doesn't have to be north or south
or east or west or moon or it these are
a little bizarre in my opinion you know
moons Emma you're too old and you're too
young to know that one Frank Zappa here
yeah kids were moon and Dweezil or
something those are unique yeah yeah Wow
Wow this has been so much fun I know
thank you miss Bergen absolutely better
huge plan yes it was good there's a lot
of fun it's crazy stuff and talked about
for a while yeah yeah yeah good to hear
that and and also just so nice to unpack
your journey and also nice to unpack
just the importance of speech and debate
and I really hope that for all those
that tuned in we greatly appreciate you
tuning and we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on that
but so let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations and your friends
families coroner's people online about
speech and debate about all this nuance
that we unpacked about those those two
fields as well as just bringing more
nuance to our conversations around our
world and the importance of funding the
Speech and Debate that are happening
within schools and organizations and
popularizing that more for even adults
and
kids in our world let's get that
happening everyone check out
Jennifer's links in the bio below and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organization's around your communities
that you believe in and around the world
support them and help them grow support
simulation our links are below you can
contribute to us on patreon
cryptocurrency PayPal or design cool
merch and get paid all those options are
below and also go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]